and there's challenges to that because
if they're not happy with you if they
don't like you if they don't see the
value of you you'll know that quickly
but there's a positive to that and the
positive to that is it forces you
right away to demonstrate your value
welcome to 20 minute leaders just sit
back relax and learn from the leaders of
today it's a journey each one is
different unique inspiring let's get
started
[Music]
this episode is powered by jventures a
community driven vc fund in silicon
valley in partnership with lomitek and
sponsored by homework ventures hippo
insurance opposed hillel stanford leap
and birthright excel
welcome to 20 minute leaders let's talk
about law firms in the startup world and
what that's like
meet jeremy lussman partner and head of
israel country group dla piper uslp
jeremy is the founder of the israeli
office for one of the world's largest
global law firms lostman advises more
than 70 israeli tech companies a month
his office has advised more than half of
israel's unicorn and sunicorn companies
worth more than a billion dollars and
many of the companies have gone public
on the nasdaq market in new york
he currently coordinates and helps lead
dla piper's development efforts and
initiatives cultivating international
business emanating from israel
serves as a liaison for israeli clients
seeking legal guidance in non-israeli
jurisdictions where dla piper has a
presence and provides guidance to
non-israeli clients evaluating business
relationships and strategic partners
within israel
jeremy lussman welcome to 20 minutes
leaders how are you today
thanks michael i'm doing great how are
you thank you so much for good i'm so
excited to be speaking to you learning
about your journey uh both personally
with your career but also with the dla
piper you know the way that you're
integrating into the israeli ecosystem
both on a regional but but also on a
global level and and and i and just in
general have a fun conversation with you
so jeremy tell me a little bit about
yourself the first one that you
mentioned to me you know right before we
started this conversation is you know
you often like to debunk this idea that
the lawyers are just boring you know as
a tech entrepreneur you know engineer
tell me a little bit about your life and
what it's like to be a lawyer
right so uh thank you again for having
me on to the show it's it's really great
um you know i've been in the ecosystem i
moved to israel about 12 years ago i've
been practicing law for over 20 um
came from the states obviously you could
tell from my accent um and i and i feel
that the israeli ecosystem has really
been phenomenal for for me from a growth
perspective because it's given me so
much opportunity to interact with so
many great entrepreneurs and companies
and find a way of
demonstrating value quickly i think you
know coming from the u.s there's very
much sort of
there's a level of cordiality but
there's also a level of
of being removed from
topless from just sort of tell me as it
is you come to the israeli ecosystem and
there's you have to you have to
recognize that people are going to tell
you how they feel
quickly right and and there's challenges
to that because if they're not happy
with you if they don't like you if they
don't see the value of you you'll know
that quickly but there's a positive to
that and the positive to that is it
forces you right away to demonstrate
your value this is why it's important
that we have this conversation this is
why it's important that you do me me
because here's what i could do for you
or here's ways that i think that i could
demonstrate value and so you know coming
in with the
you know recognizing that lawyers
oftentimes are viewed as service
providers lawyers are oftentimes viewed
as the group that's going to tell me
what i can't do as opposed to what i can
do
um you know i sort of look at it as no
lawyers are major facilitators lawyers
have really
a phenomenal opportunity of becoming
trusted advisors
to the companies that they're servicing
and if you can come in in a way and show
ways that you can
show value demonstrate um your your your
ability to add to a business to add to a
person
then uh you know then then that creates
i would say a level of trust and a level
of comfort
early on and so for me moving to the
ecosystem in in israel and and sort of
bearing that in mind
so you know in my mind still you know
lawyers the responsibility is to take
whatever agreement the founder or the
entrepreneur already made
now formalize it in a way that that many
people won't really understand that
there's a joke of course but but but how
do you then position yourself you know
as a legal firm as a lawyer to be a part
of the strategizing process and not on
the execution process of just
formalizing the decision that was
already made
it's a great question um i think that it
all goes to becoming doing whatever you
can to become a trusted advisor when you
think about like who your core group of
trusted advisors are the people that you
want to have at the table because you
value their counsel you trust their
judgment at the end of the day how does
a lawyer come into a relationship and
change
change you know normally they're coming
in in a way that you described meaning
someone is coming to a law firm because
they need some sort of execution we're
opening a branch in london we're hiring
an employee in ireland we're signing an
agreement in italy or signing a lease in
america um
you know a lawyer has to be able to
execute and that's oftentimes where i
come into a relationship but at the end
of the day you i work very hard at
trying to develop trust and create the
connection and the friendship so that
the next time around the entrepreneur
will say you know what like i want to
have jeremy and his team at the table
with us earlier you know they they
worked with us last time they know how
we think they know what we care about
they know how to help us strategize and
think about the most topless oriented
way of doing something so as opposed to
me entrepreneur coming to jeremy saying
i want you to sign this agreement i want
you to help me execute this agreement
maybe he has different thoughts on the
best way of executing this maybe there's
a better way of approaching the other
side maybe there's more of a win-win
approach that we can sort of address
from the beginning as opposed to kind of
coming in and uh you know and more of a
challenging dynamic so you know i think
we come into relationships however we
come into them at whatever point in time
but how do you sort of get into the
consciousness of entrepreneurs earlier
on so that they want you at the table as
as an advisor you know from from from an
earlier or an earlier point in time do
you find that entrepreneurs or you know
different entrepreneurs at different
stages how do they react when they meet
you and they see that okay maybe maybe
they're first-time entrepreneurs and
their perception of the the way that
they're going to work with their lawyer
is actually different from what they're
getting or what they could get with what
you're offering them
right it's a great it's also a great
question i i think with us
there's a lot of value because we have a
team that are sitting in israel and
we're not we're not um
we're our firm's investment into the
israeli ecosystem so people can talk to
us people can meet with us they're not
being charged for doing that you know
the only time that we're charging is
when we get retained for a project and
we involve one of our other offices
around the world so i think we make it
we make it very easy for people you know
we make it very easy to hey you know no
matter how big or small your issues are
you're a smaller company and you're
thinking about hiring your first
employee in the united states great
let's think about the easiest most
practical way of doing that you're at a
later stage and you're bringing in
significant financing from
an investor in the far east okay let's
think about the best way of doing that
and sometimes it's a matter of getting
to know your clients well sometimes it's
a matter of sharing best practices with
them right
it's being able to say okay here's what
we've seen your your colleagues in the
market do that that's worked well for
them but also you know what if you're
thinking of doing something in australia
why don't we get on the phone with a
couple of my colleagues in australia and
you know ask whatever questions you want
let's let's
um brainstorm together
so that you can become smarter about the
best way of functioning and so what that
enables us to do is it allows us to
become part of the conversation early on
and to bring the right resources and
then the other thing that we work very
hard at doing i recognize we're part of
a big organization we're in 45 countries
more than 45 countries around the world
we're very well networked
around the world and i think that
lawyers as a as a group kind of going to
the original question lawyers as a group
are often reactive you wait for a client
to approach you and you have to be able
to execute but i think that there's a
real missed opportunity for lawyers to
be much more proactive to say you know
what
what can i do to help you drive your
business what are things that you might
not be thinking about and you know what
can i do to help help you grow and in my
particular case because i happen to be a
partner in one of the world's largest
law firms so if you are looking to grow
in europe well maybe we have contacts in
europe that can be great you know
potential
customers for you or points of contact
or prospective investors you know there
are a lot of opportunities to connect
dots not as not as a mocker like we
don't get paid for anything
you know for anything outside of legal
work but i think we recognize you know
what like if i just come to another
company and say hey i'm a lawyer i'd
love to meet you you know chances are
they're
the response will be like okay that's
very nice take a number get to the back
of the line we already know other other
lawyers we already work with this firm
we already work for that firm but if you
come and say i know you're already
working with this firm or that firm but
here's why i think i could be relevant
to you i saw that you just raised money
and you
expressed your interest in growing in
brazil colombia argentina mexico and
canada and we're the only firm that's
sitting in israel that has offices in
all of those locations and not only can
we do your legal work in those places
but you know we can open doors for you
we can help educate you we can connect
dots for you and i think sort of being
part of the conversation in that type of
proactive way
has made us
you know more more relevant to more and
more conversations definitely and i
think that you're alluding to to another
question that i had you know i'm
thinking about myself starting a company
you know at some point and you know
there's so many different pieces that
i've thought about rigorously you know
who my partners are going to be who am i
who i want my investors to be
who do i want my customers to be i
didn't think about who i want my lawyers
to be and you know what i'm what's
resonating throughout this conversation
is that this is actually a pretty big
part of you know the startup journey and
and you know the legal firm that is
going to help me and represent me is
just a bigger part of my journey perhaps
is even my investors or my partners
what's happening
yeah hopefully after hope hope hopefully
after this conversation you won't have
to think about if you're always going to
be impressed so
why why is it
do you think that still today i don't i
didn't think about this question before
this conversation and the fall question
to that is going to be you know what
what should my considerations be you
know rigorously as i'm thinking okay i'm
going to start a company and i want to
choose the right partners for me
yeah i think it's i think it's you know
it's it's multi-fold i think it's
looking at
your service providers as your partners
not just as hired help and if you look
at them as your partners and you empower
them as your partners and they're going
to feel hey you know i'm here to you
know i'm invested in this company you
know i'm looking for this company to to
grow and develop and be strong and you
know that's good for my client and my
new friends and at the end of the we all
have our self-interest in our own
business if they do well then hopefully
there's more and more opportunity you
know to grow with them but i think it
also in the world that we're in now
specifically even in the last like two
years
i would say really like since covid just
coins coincidentally i think that there
are a lot of legal points that companies
are looking at less in a check the box
kind of a way oh i have to like you know
cya and just do that because you know i
want to make sure that like a regulator
is not going to collect gdpr for example
privacy right is which is a huge area
for so many companies in your you know
in your ecosystem um privacy figuring
out how to be compliant is is critical
for you know for most high-tech
companies and i would say years ago when
they started thinking down the privacy
track they were saying okay
what do i need to do like what's the big
what's the bare minimum of what i need
to do or if a regulator knocks on my
door tomorrow
you know what what do i have to
accomplish so that i won't get in
trouble you know and it's much more of a
defensive mechanism as opposed to
more and more investors are putting more
and more money into these companies and
the more that they are
um regulatory
um hygienic from a regulatory
perspective the more that it's a
creative to value you know the more that
companies can say wow this company has
their stuff in order you know this is i
don't i don't have to like think about
what can go wrong in the same way
because they've already set up a data
room they've already shown that they've
hired sophisticated
a finance people
sophisticated legal people you know to
be able to help to help them grow and
drive them and you know at the end of
the day i'm more comfortable
um you know valuing them higher because
the skeletons in the closet are
you know much lower right like at the
end of the day if i'm if i'm an investor
coming into your company and you can
show that investor you know what i take
i take my regulation my regulatory
compliance very seriously here's what
i've done here's who i've hired here's
what we've already done here's the
roadmap that we're following
investors are gonna
you know become more and more
comfortable with you quicker and i think
that there's a lot of talk about your
journey your trajectory you know why get
into law and then specifically within
law the tech ecosystem and within the
tech ecosystem
why go on this journey to be a such a
strategic partner
with with startup companies
well so i mean my journey has in some
ways it's uh traditional but in other
ways it it it um it changed and i was
given a real opportunity to sort of have
a mid-career switch you know i grew up
on the east coast in the states uh you
know jewish family went to yeshiva day
school i would say in the world of
yeshiva day school when i was growing up
you know the
traditional career paths were
doctor lawyer
accountant rabbi
you know maybe you know maybe one or two
others you know so you know i was sort
of brought up in a world where okay you
know there are some traditional career
paths i i was interested in in law early
on i think in part because there were
some there were great television shows
that were legal dramas um that were
there and and i was i was just um
interested in that i knew that i wasn't
interested in medicine i had a lot of
family members who were lawyers and i
you know and and what i was always
taught about being a lawyer is that you
know
law opens many doors for you
um
law doesn't sort of pigeonhole you into
a particular
sector law can open more and more doors
to business because what what being a
lawyer does what going to law school
does but more practical leaving lawyers
it it requires you to think it requires
you to sort of um
project out of the box and to you know
and to try and um
um
and to try and think things through in a
much more holistic way so i think kind
of going down the law school route for
me was a combination of
ruling out certain other career paths
and thinking about law as something that
could be a stepping stone to
more and more doors opening up um you
know i went to law school in the states
i practiced in the states for nine years
um in um six years for dll in within
within my firm now dla three years for a
different firm beforehand um but what
ended up happening at the end of 2008
beginning of 2009 was the markets around
the world were crashing
it was a really really challenging time
and for anybody who was a corporate
lawyer
or a banker or a vc like credit was
completely dead you know after lehman
fell
um and enron and just sort of there were
a number of stories that um and
companies that went south
so there was a really really challenging
time for traditional lawyers in
traditional law firms and thank god i
didn't lose my job but a lot of my
colleagues did and i really felt
vulnerable for the first time
in my career from that perspective and
what i ended up having the privilege of
doing was
really making um lemonade out of lemons
you know was essentially my wife and i
for years had spoken about the
possibility of spending more time in
israel we had three young kids at the
time we said you know what this could be
like a blessing in in disguise maybe
there's an opportunity my firm dla was
growing internationally we were
contracting in the us
at that point in time and i said you
know what if i stay here in the u.s my
job becomes more and more more
vulnerable you know maybe there's an
opportunity to throw out an israel
practice to the firm israel seems to be
weathering the storm
much
in a much better way
obviously the level of innovation and
entrepreneurship in israel is amazing
you know and maybe there's an
opportunity to try to develop a practice
there and so
i threw the idea out to the firm it was
almost like shooting a dart you know and
hoping that it landed in the right spot
and you know with with god's help it
really did the the manukau the ceo of
our firm at the time was jewish the
partners that i was senior partners in
my office in washington that i was
connected to were very
um supportive um i i i um put skin in
the game you know meaning and during
that period of time when firms were not
spending a lot of money i said you know
what don't i'm not looking for this to
be a boondoggle like just pay me enough
that i can support my family but let me
let me go for a year and try to develop
the opportunity here and the worst case
scenario is it's a total failure and if
it's a total failure a year from now
i'll have to look for a new job yeah but
you know what but maybe it won't be a
total failure and i think really picking
up on the israeli
um you know the israeli um one of the
cornerstones of the israeli
um
entrepreneur scene is you know
don't fear failure you know no is okay
don't be afraid of no you know nobody
wants failure but
you're not gonna
you're not gonna get places unless you
try and unless you make the best and
most concerted effort and so i think
early on the idea of you know what like
the worst case scenario is it's a
failure but you know what what happens
if it's a failure in the in the worst
case i gave my family the opportunity to
go to israel for a year i worked hard to
develop a business
and you know obviously i'll be better
for that thankfully
it wasn't a failure thankfully you know
the stars aligned and you know we ended
up yeah 12 years later we have a really
incredible you know gr grateful we have
a really successful practice we work
with over 70 companies a month we
um you know really represent israeli
companies in any given year in over 35
40 different jurisdictions and
yeah thank god you know thank god i have
a lot to be grateful for you know
there's a lot of gratitude going around
i love it i love it where do you gather
your inspiration from today so you wake
up you work with 70 companies a month
you continue
meeting new companies
not just you know doing their legal work
but but being active and strategizing
with them and understanding their
markets and opening doors you know
where's the inspiration from on a daily
level i would say the inspiration for me
is being
as well-rounded as possible i think it's
beginning the day as early as possible
doing some studying being grateful to
you know god for all the blessings that
we have i think it's um spending time
with my family every day i'm married
thank god i have three kids um 21 almost
19 and 16 two girls and a boy
and you know just being grateful for the
blessing of children and um trying to
you know be connected to my personal
world uh as much as i can you know
trying to exercise and trying to just
sort of check the box for
um being fulfilled on on you know
various levels outside of work and then
within work i would say it's just you
know having a great team that i work
with i come to work every day now now
grateful that it's back in person most
of the time but even during corona just
having great friends and colleagues that
i feel so connected to
um
and and and and looking at every day is
something very different in my world
there's no no two days are are the same
i don't know who's gonna approach me i
don't know what countries they're gonna
be dealing with i don't know what issues
they're gonna have and so you know for
us it's
looking at every day as as a gift and a
real opportunity and i and i and i also
just gained a tremendous amount of
inspiration from the ability in israel
to create close friendships with your
clients i feel that
in the us and in europe there's a real
barrier between
service providers and their clients
that's not to say that you don't get
along well
you get along well with your clients but
i feel that there is a
um
a very clear separation between
professionals and their clients and you
know and personal life versus
professional life and so you know in in
in those countries you might say how was
your weekend that's very nice but i feel
like in israel there's a level of
intimacy
that you know you get to know your
clients much better you you know how
many kids and where are they exactly
come for shabbat or you run into them in
the gym or you know let's grab a quick
coffee and there's a level of
connectiveness that really small
yeah
exactly exactly so um yeah i i gain
inspiration from all of those things
jeremy
thank you very very much this was so
nice and i'm excited to reach out when i
have my own startup and then get to know
you better thank you
michael
thank you and stay safe thank you thank
you so much for the opportunity you as
well
of course okay take care